that's 2,000 so Cheryl leaves Washington
2001 comes to Silicon Valley looking for
work hangs out of my office for like I
don't know a month or six weeks and
initially she thinks she wants to go in
the investment business and then my
partner John Powell goes now that's
insane she's gonna be the greatest
manager to come on in Silicon Valley of
this era we got to get her to Google and
of course we're inside the offices of
kleiner perkins so it's literally three
doors down to John doors office Weiner
who Cheryl to John the rest as they say
is history
then in 2007 she's calling me and saying
hey I am gonna leave Google go dilash
posing like you can't do that you got to
go to Facebook and she goes he's 23
that'll never work
and I'm going hanging his mom is a
physician she's a doctor and like a
psychologist and he's got nothing but
sisters he's gonna be that rare Silicon
Valley guy who can work with women you
take my word for it so I got a mark I go
mark I think I know who you need to hire
he'd hire Sheryl Sandberg he goes she
works at Google like somehow that was a
problem right he's going like gules
nothing like Facebook and I'm going yeah
like what is give me a break dude how
are you gonna get in closer I said she's
scaled she bad Google ad network well
yeah she certainly scaled it right me
yeah there was one he created it yeah no
I mean she and Marissa and Susan yeah
all and you know there are obviously
other people but they I think they as a
team crafted but Cheryl's job was to
scale it right and to scale the ad sales
and all that stuff which is a huge job
and that was gonna be exactly the same
thing at Facebook so anyway it took a
couple months to get the two of them to
meet each other and once they did they
hit it off right away and there's
naturally Cheryl goes to work there and
so it is the perfect combination when
you think about it because Sheryl is so
able to like Bill Clinton or other folks
she is able to connect with people
instantly make them feel heard she
understands soft power hard power all of
these things she's a consummate diplomat
people say she would be a great
president secretary of state whatever
and then Mark is you know it might be a
little bit cruel
but you know some that live and other
comedy shows will pin him as being kind
of Asperger you're on the spectrum which
who knows but it does seem like that's a
perfect balance in that she's great at
being the front person and talking to
people and then he's great at putting
his head down and just so eyes are
focusing am i right I said I I thought
I'm so first of all I have no reason to
push back on that at all but I would say
the way I saw it was that he had a
strategic vision and she is the single
best tactician hmm I encountered in
Silicon Valley post and E growth okay no
I mean huge
so I'm saying I've been blessed I mean I
you know because I was there before the
PC industry was an industry I was lucky
enough to get to know you know Gordon
Moore and Andy Grove it in tell him to
get to know Steve Jobs and Bill Gates
and you know Larry Ellison and all the
other people helped to build the valley
and the thing is there have been some
amazing entrepreneurs and executives but
Cheryl is gonna be on the shortest list
in terms of just getting stuff done and
she was exactly what mark needed I mean
I think her communication skills in my
opinion were a massive plus but her
ability to be organized and to be a
tactician like mark sits there and sets
the direction how do you get there
I mean her she's really special on that
and so oh I remember when I met him
early on he was just he hated
advertising so the idea that he can
offload it to the advertising expert
yeah who had built the largest most
disruptive ad network yeah I helped
build it so anyway I thought the two of
them were amazing together